[Guilhem] Oui ?
[Cyrus] J'ai ta réponse !
De quoi ? Nan mais t'étais pas obligé de...
[C] Je peux rentrer ?
[G] Bah ...
[C] Merci !
[C] Mec c'est ouf c'est genre comme dans tes vidéos quoi. T'as une pièce YouTube !
[G] Bah nan c'est pas ma pièce YouTube c'est ma chambre
Fin c'est comme dans mes vidéos parce que c'est là que je tourne mes vidéos
Mais t'sais tu veux pas genre...
[C] Un verre d'eau ? J'osais pas te le demander en vrai !
T'es trop sympa !
Euh...Alors c'est bon je m'installe là comme ça je réponds à ta question ?
[G] Baaah pfff
[C] Et euh et voilà, merci ça défonce mec d'être là
Alors Guillem m'a envoyé une, fin Guilhem
Guilhem, c'est Guilhem
Excuse-moi
Pas de soucis
Il m'a envoyé une question qui était : "Est-ce que c'est mal d'être superficiel ?"
Ouais
Alors la superficialité en gros, c'est euh, ce qui est limité à la surface
C'est ce qui n'est qu'apparent
Ça se dit des gens qui s’intéressent pas aux réalités profondes
Et du coup
On dit, lorsqu'on dit de quelqu'un qu'il est superficiel, c'est assez péjoratif tu vois
C'est genre on va dire qu'il a une absence d'opinion,
un manque de culture,
limite un déficit intellectuel, fin bref, c'est des trucs vraiment pas cool
Par exemple, des gens qu'on pourrait considérer comme a priori superficiels,
C'est les youtubeuses beauté et les youtubeurs beauté
De quoi les youtubeurs beauté ?
Bah ils sont un peu superficiels
Pffffff, je trouve pas
Du coup la superficialité c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est vu comme négatif
Par exemple quand Zuckerberg nous dit :
" Je porte toujours le même T-shirt, dans le même modèle et la même couleur "
C'est une manière de nous dire: voilà, je perds pas mon temps dans des décisions superficielles,
Moi au moins je m'investis dans des choses profondes
J'investis mon temps dans ça quoi
Ouais enfin Zuckerberg, si c'était vraiment le "génie" dont tout le monde parle,
il aurait pas pris un gris qui est plus à la mode depuis au moins mai 2014 quoi
Sérieux, c'est plus à la mode du tout ?
Nan c'est pas vraiment ce gris là, c'était un autre, fin c'était pas...
Tu veux que je te file un T-shirt ?
Nan mec je suis pas superficiel !
Comme tu veux
Moi je pense qu'il faut distinguer deux types de superficialité:
Déjà y a le superficiel des youtubeurs beauté ou life style,
dont tu fais une excellente satire sur ta chaîne d'ailleurs
Ah ouais
Attends c'est quoi satire ?
T'es vraiment excellent !
Bah non je, je vois pas ce que... fin c'est quoi satire ?
Donc ce premier type de superficialité pour moi c'est une question de goût et de passion quoi
De la même façon qu'on puisse être passionné
de j'sais pas moi, chevaux, automobiles ou philo,
eh ben on peut aussi l'être de make up, mode, ce genre de choses.
Y a pas des passions qui soient mieux que d'autres
Ah enfin la philo c'est quand même un peu pourri comme passion
Ah bon pourquoi ?
Bah non mais je dis pas ça pour toi euh
Moi je sais que tu t'en fous de la philo: tu as pris ça parce qu'y restait plus que ça sur Youtube, mais euh fin c'est pas...
Quoi ?!?
Ouais, fin non c'est pas grave ... t'inquiète laisse tomber...
La superficialité
Bah si on essaye de creuser, on se rend compte qu'en fait ces passions qui seraient pourries...
C'est des passions qui sont peut-être pas profondes ...
Qui portent pas de vrais combats ou des idées nobles
Et bah là, on arrive au second type de superficialité.
Celui qui ne touche pas juste à une affaire de goût mais qui est plus global.
C'est celui qui est lié à la profondeur des choses.
Par exemple, je peux être passionné de philo mais la traiter superficiellement.
Et en vrai, "Pourquoi la superficialité ça serait un mal ?"
Bah ouais, c'est justement le sens de ma question.
Oui, je sais. J'y réponds là.
Bah, c'est long ... [Toussote]
Quoi?
Non, je dis c'est bon. J'ai compris, c'est bon.
D'accord.
Moi, ce qui me déplaît lorsqu'on dit que le profond est plus intéressant
C'est que bah, quelque part, on dénigre la superficialité
On dénigre l'apparence. On se moque d'elle alors que l'apparence, le superficiel, ça a une valeur par elle-même.
Lorsque je vous parle des océans, on parle du fond des abysses mais aussi de la surface.
Ah, c'est un peu comme avec la peau par exemple, quand on veut la traiter.
Faut la traiter en profondeur avec l'alimentation mais aussi en superficialité avec tout ce qui est make up !
Exactement, ouais. Tout à fait.
D'ailleurs ! En parlant de make up, je voulais ... enfin non t'inquiète. Laisse tomber.
Nan vas-y dis.
Non non t'sais parce que moi je suis vraiment très très make up donc si tu me lances maintenant je vais pas m'arrêter …
J'ai un .. un bout... C'est à cause de ça là ?
Non, non. C'est un ensemble.
Celui qui a un problème avec cette superficialité
Avec cette apparence et qui cherche à tout prix quelque chose de profond
C'est celui qui a forcément besoin de se raccrocher à quelque chose parce qu'il a peur de se faire emporter par ...
Par l'écume quoi, par les frivolités.
C'est quelque chose qui nous vient de Nietzsche qui pensait que le fait d'être superficiel,
c'était pour les esprits libres qui n'ont pas besoin de se rassurer en pensant que derrière les apparences, il y a des vérités plus importantes.
Ah oui, c'est euh. Du coup c'est bien d'être superficiel ?
Ouais ! Ouais. Bah regarde deux secondes les grecs par exemple:
Si on pense aux grecs qui passaient leur temps à admirer les belles choses.
Et même à l'associer au bien. Ce qu'on appelle Kalos Kagathos.
C'est ce que je vous avais dit dans le premier ask.
Et bien on ne peut pas dire que les grecs étaient quand même non profonds.
Ouais, c'est pour ça que Nietzsche dit qu'ils sont "superficiels par profondeur".
Ouais, mais carrément. Tu connais Nietzsche ?
Ah non, pas du tout. J'étais sur Evene, j'ai tapé "superficialité" et c'est le premier truc qui est sorti.
En plus de ça, le superficiel fait forcément  écho à des choses qui sont profondes.
Ouais, ouais, regarde par exemple nous, les youtubeuses beauté, bah ça parait superficiel
Mais y'a des vraies valeurs d'entraide et de partage.
Exactement. Et ça c'est du côté du mec qui est acteur de la superficialité.
Mais on peut aussi être spectateur.
C'est-à-dire qu'on peut s'indigner profondément de quelque chose qui n'est qu'apparence.
Par exemple, on peut profondément s'indigner du dernier vernis de je-ne-sais-qui, je ...
Han ! M'en parle pas. Je sais très bien de qui tu parles. C'était une blague ce vernis.
Avec les filles on a pas arrêté d'en parler. Ça a été genre  [souffle]
En fait, à partir du moment où la superficialité a un vrai impact "Est-ce qu'il faut la dénigrer ?"
Bah moi je pense que …
Non, non mais c'était une question rhétorique. La réponse est «non».
Bah, pourquoi tu le dis pas directement alors ?
Bah ... Non, non. Il faut pas la dénigrer.
Après les apparences elles sont parfois trompeuses c'est vrai.
Mais, on peut pas contourner les apparences si on veut comprendre les choses globalement.
Donc, si je devais résumer, je dirais que non, c'est pas un mal d'être superficiel.
La superficialité n'est pas à dénigrer par rapport à la profondeur.
Que ce soit une question de hobbie ou une volonté globale de ne pas s'engouffrer dans les choses pour pouvoir goûter un peu de tout quoi.
Ah donc toi tu dis qu'en fait, ce qui est mal, c'est d'être un expert. 'Fin d'être un geek.
Bah non, pourquoi ça serait un mal ?
J'sais pas ..
Et je pense que, pour conclure, on peut dire comme Nietzsche que :
"Quiconque a sondé le fond des choses, devine sans peine quelle sagesse il y a à rester superficiel"
C'était pas mal mec hein.
J'ai bien dit?
Ouais, ouais. Tu l'as vraiment bien dit.
Parce que j'ai pas compris ce que ça voulait dire mais tu m'as dit de le dire ...
T'inquiète, t'inquiète. Ça rentre parfaitement dans ce qu'on s'est dit.
Mais du coup, ça t'as plu ? Ça va ?
Ouais ouais ouais carrément.
Ça répond à ta question?
Ouais ouais carrément. 'Fin je pense que je regarderais la vidéo pour la... 'Fin je verrai.
Bah ouais. En tout cas ça me fait vraiment plaisir du coup de faire cette collab' et tout avec toi.
Ouais.
Parce que j'adore tes vid... Je t'avoue y'a un truc, mec, quand je regarde les vidéos des youtubeuses et tout ...
Je me dis, ça serait marrant de faire un tag. Mais tu vois genre sur ma chaîne ça a pas de ... ça a pas trop de sens quoi, d'en faire un ...
Tu veux en faire un sur ma chaîne ? Vas-y moi je ... y'a pas de soucis !
Là, là?
Ouais, carrément. Bah tant qu'on y est. Y'a la caméra et tout. On peut en faire un.
Bah carrément! Bah, vous savez quoi? Sinon, cliquez ici et comme ça vous pouvez voir tout de suite le tag qu'on fait sur la chaîne de Guilhem. Masculin Singulier.
En tout cas, j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu.
Si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à faire un retour dans les commentaires et à me dire ce que vous en avez pensé.
Merci à Guilhem de Masculin Singulier qui a une chaîne que j'apprécie et qui me fait beaucoup rire donc ça m'a fait plaisir de taffer avec lui sur ce sujet là.
On se retrouve bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo. Je vous envoie du love et de la peace